Marvel movies are for kids… right?
Well, based on the jump scares and scary imagery,
"Doctor Strange 2" is apparently for making
kids cry.
Here are all the things only adults noticed
in the surprisingly frightening "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness."
The one thing that was abundantly clear about
America Chavez in "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness" was that she had seen a lot.
Having traveled across the Multiverse, she
had visited 72 universes before landing on
Earth-616.
However, there was one superhero she had failed
to encounter or even know anything about during
her adventures: Spider-Man.
While most people might point out that it's
because of Doctor Strange's spell at the end
of "Spider-Man: No Way Home," that's not an
entirely correct assumption.
Strange's spell made everyone forget that
Peter Parker existed, not Spidey.
Even Happy Hogan confirmed to Pete that he
knew Aunt May through Spider-Man at her gravesite.
Taking into account the three Spider-Men that
appeared in "No Way Home," plus all the others
introduced in "Into the Spider-Verse," what
are the odds that America only visited universes
without any spider-themed heroes or variants?
No Miles Morales?
No Miguel O'Hara?
No Spider-Gwen?
Hmm ... This is starting to smell a whole
lot like a gigantic plot hole.
Wanda Maximoff experienced a heartbreaking
and life-changing moment when she removed
the Mind Stone from Vision's head, which was
a vital part of keeping him alive.
Then, she had to suffer the pain and loss
all over again, as Thanos reversed time and
destroyed the android once more for good measure.
These events can change someone – and in
Wanda's case, they had a big effect, as we
all saw in "WandaVision."
Her grieving process was, to say the least,
ethically questionable.
"If you won't let us go, just let us die."
While we cannot condone Wanda's actions or
methods, her former teammates hardly made
any effort to provide her comfort during her
period of grief.
Sure, everyone experienced their own losses
after Thanos' snap and had a lot to deal with,
but no one attempted to even be a shoulder
to cry on for Wanda, even knowing that she'd
lost her brother, Pietro, and then the love
of her life.
In all likelihood, Wanda might have pushed
them away, but at least she would have known
they cared about her.
Ultimately, she was alone and this led her
to the Darkhold and the path of trying to
create a family to deal with her trauma.
With friends like the Avengers, who needs
enemies, right?
"And now… it's time for some good news."
Undoubtedly, one of the hottest cameos of
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
was the appearance of John Krasinski as the
Reed Richards, aka Mister Fantastic, of Earth-838.
While social media might have spoiled the
big reveal because Film Twitter cannot contain
itself with secrets, it was still an exciting
moment, as it announced the official arrival
of the Fantastic Four in the MCU.
The rest of Marvel's First Family didn't show
up, but it was more than enough to lay a solid
foundation for the impending film.
With the confirmation that the Fantastic Four
exists within the multiverse, it leaves one
major question here: Why didn't the Earth-616
version of the team try to stop Thanos with
the Avengers?
Yes, Krasinski's Mister Fantastic was from
a different universe, but there must be other
versions of the Fantastic Four sprinkled throughout
the Multiverse.
Are we meant to believe that Reed Richards
— one of the world's greatest minds — didn't
have anything to add and chose to stay at
home in the Baxter Building while the rest
of Earth's heroes battled Thanos' evil forces?
They must've been busy with something interesting.
Maybe we'll get some answers in the upcoming
movie.
Fox's X-Men series ended quietly with the
release of The New Mutants, preceded by the
purchase of 20th Century Fox by Disney.
But long before that purchase, the "canon"
of the X-Men movies had become hopelessly
confusing.
That timeline has undergone more revamps and
reimaginings than "Extreme Makeover: Home
Edition."
Without a doubt, the MCU will try to remedy
this situation with the Children of the Atom
becoming a part of the greater Marvel Universe,
and the first step was introducing the Earth-838
version of Patrick Stewart's Professor Charles
Xavier in "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness."
While Stewart's Professor X was from Fox's
X-Verse, there are a few hints that he may
be the mutant from another popular incarnation
of the X-Men.
When Professor X appeared in the film, he
glided onto the screen in the recognizable
yellow hover chair from "X-Men: The Animated
Series."
Additionally, he wore a green top to match
the character's design from the cartoon.
However, the biggest a-ha moment was when
a hint of the classic theme song from the
animated show played in the background.
Of course this could be a homage or merely
fan service for long-time supporters of the
mutant superheroes, but wouldn't it be a novel
idea if "X-Men: The Animated Series" ends
up being the backstory of the MCU's X-Men?
With the animated show returning with the
upcoming sequel series "X-Men '97" on Disney+,
don't bet against it.
The fact that the title of the film includes
"Multiverse of Madness" is a good indication
that not everything was meant to make sense
here.
However, there was one glaring issue that
cannot be overlooked.
Remember "Spider-Man: No Way Home" and how
it brought all the Peter Parkers together?
While it was fun to hear MJ and Ned call Peter
and for all of them to respond at the same
time, it was evident that all three Peters
looked different and were distinguishable
from each other.
"This is Peter Parker, this is Peter Parker,
Spider-Man, Spider-Man, they're mes from other universes."
"Oh, no."
So why did the variants of Stephen Strange,
Christine Palmer, and Wanda Maximoff all look
the same in the Multiverse?
Apart from a different haircut or some slightly
different attire, they all looked identical.
It was easy to spot who they were, and the
shared features made them instantly recognizable
to people from other universes.
Using this logic, all three of the Spider-Men
should have looked like Tom Holland's version
of the character.
Naturally, this new logic could be a result
of Doctor Strange's spells having adverse
effects on the Multiverse, but it still seemed
peculiar how America Chavez, who had been
traversing the universes for some time, didn't
mention anything about it.
In Earth-616, Iron Man sacrificed himself
to end Thanos' reign of terror.
In "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness,"
it was shown how the Illuminati also brought
down the Mad Titan in their own universe.
Connecting the dots, this points to one significant
conclusion: There are multiple versions of
Thanos throughout the Multiverse and they're
all likely hungry for power.
"Impossible."
As portals have been opened and people have
zipped in and out of the different universes,
what are the odds that another Thanos hasn't
slipped through the cracks as well?
His brother Eros, aka Starfox, was introduced
in the post-credits scene of "Eternals;" a
powerful figure like him will need a formidable
foe, and who is more formidable than his brother,
the Mad Titan?
A villain as big and monumental as Thanos
doesn't just go away quietly after one rumble.
It's not outside the realm of possibility
that some version of him may be laying low
and licking his wounds, as he plots his revenge
on Earth's Mightiest Heroes and prepares to
strike once again.
Previous MCU films have made it clear that
Wanda Maximoff is a powerful character; you
may recall that she appeared capable of defeating
Thanos almost single-handedly.
However, as the Scarlet Witch in "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness," she showed
off just how OP she really was.
Not only did she wipe out Captain Carter,
Captain Marvel, Reed Richards, and Black Bolt
on her own, but she also wiped out the army
of Kamar-Taj without breaking a sweat.
Forget about great power and great responsibility,
because when someone holds the potential to
get into people's heads and snap them like
they're twigs, it's best to put pride aside
and call in the heavy guns for help.
For some reason, though, Doctor Strange didn't
do that.
He knew that Scarlet Witch was heading to
Kamar-Taj to collect America Chavez, and she
had already told him her demands beforehand.
Yet, instead of phoning up the Avengers and
asking for some superpowered backup, he decided
to rely on magic students as the frontline
of defense.
Perhaps Strange underestimated his former
colleague, but he could have at least called
up Jimmy Woo and Darcy Lewis to find out how
much damage the Scarlet Witch had caused at Westview.
Maybe then he wouldn't have been so reluctant
to seek out major assistance in the first place.
When Doctor Strange tried to reason with Scarlet
Witch about the severe consequences of messing
with the Multiverse, she turned the tables
and pointed out how it was deemed acceptable
when he did the same.
"You break the rules and become a hero; I
do it and I become the enemy."
She says it's not fair, and she's not wrong.
While there was an element of whataboutism
in her response, she raised a valid point
about Strange's double standards.
In "Spider-Man: No Way Home," Wong warned
him about what would happen, but Strange didn't
heed his warnings.
Instead, he opened the world to possible new
threats because of a request from Spider-Man.
While it was undoubtedly sad that Spidey's
true identity was exposed to the world, Strange
was prepared to risk the safety of the entire
universe to reverse a single event.
Surely, there were other solutions here.
Even if it meant that Peter Parker would have
to hide out for a period of time until they
figured it out.
Yet, the first port of call here was magic
— the kind that creates seismic rifts in
the universe.
While Scarlet Witch wasn't right in wanting
to sacrifice a person for her own delusion
of personal happiness, neither was Strange,
who was prepared to risk an entire world for
one person.
From what we have seen in the MCU, Doctor
Strange has never been what one would call
a "people person."
He can come across as prickly, condescending,
and sometimes even cruel.
"This isn't the end; there are other things
that can give your life meaning."
"Like what – like you?"
However, he displayed a lot of initial disrespect
to Wong in "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness."
When approaching the Sorcerer Supreme, there
were certain formalities that needed to be
adhered to, such as bowing before him.
For Strange, he didn't do this for the better
part of the film, only doing so in the end.
It was surprising to see Strange behave this
way, since Wong had not only been a friend,
but also the person who assisted him in studying
the Mystic Arts.
He had a wealth of knowledge and even knew
important concepts about the Multiverse that
Strange had no idea about.
Much like "Spider-Man: No Way Home," Strange
didn't listen to Wong when he really should
have.
Hopefully, his change in demeanor at the end
of "Multiverse of Madness" signified that
he would be taking Wong and his position as
the Sorcerer Supreme much more seriously in
the future.
"Oh, that's funny."
Out of all the characters from the previous
Marvel films and TV shows, who would have
put money on an Inhuman showing up in "Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"?
Lest we forget, the "Inhumans" TV show holds
an 11% critical approval rating and 44% audience
score on Rotten Tomatoes.
After all the ridicule and bad press, one
would imagine that Kevin Feige would have
sent the Inhumans into the darkest part of
the Multiverse, never to be seen again.
Yet, Anson Mount returned as Black Bolt in
Sam Raimi's film.
This time, however, he was kitted out in a
comic book-accurate outfit and portrayed as
more of an omega-level threat than what was
seen in the series.
Like his comic book counterpart, no one wanted
him to speak a word, knowing that a single
whisper could decimate anyone around him.
"Why?"
Equally important here, "Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness" proved that there
could be life and a future for the Inhumans
in the MCU.
Not that team, necessarily, but the Inhumans
in general.
They might have had a rough time on the ABC
show, but they could still play an important
part in Marvel movies going forward.
Maybe Mount may return as Black Bolt for a
third time, ensuring that Vin Diesel's long-standing
dream of playing the silent superhero never
happens.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.